hello everyone how are you guys doing I
hope you guys are having a wonderful day
today we are here with episode number 14
of noob with a mill I make a lot of
progress this episode I get a lot of
money in but I also spend a lot of money
to try to go ahead and level up my
account as fast as possible so that
being said let's get right on into the
clips all right a little bit of postc to
start off the episode you can blame my
roommate for that one about 178 bad
demons went ahead and got 96 strength on
the task which is insane I mean I'm I'm
closing in on 99 strengths like it's
just it's going to be crazy I can't wait
to start pking I just need 94 Mage but
there we go hellhounds and a neck reel
test which I can burst went ahead and
finished off the neck reels task uh
ended up getting 80 Mage on it still got
a long ways to go in Mage but going to
go ahead and get another
task God man I keep getting cave whes
like every other task and I I mean
they're terrible but they're kind of AFK
I just I don't get it I'm yet to get a
black mask on all these kills but uh
yeah got hella long bones right now so
task is over I'm going to go ahead and
see my kill count real quick on these
cuz I'm kind of interested so uh
teleport I think I can see my kill count
with the Slayer ring right check let's
check oh wait I got to wear it I think
nailed it uh log there we go okay cave
cave fors
what oh they're down here because it
goes by level yep 87 I guess it's not
that bad feels like it's been more but
oh another task in which I can uh I can
ice burst so that's pretty lit happy
about that all right so after the dust
devil task I don't end up having it but
I got a chaos Elemental task in which I
killed about another 40 I still didn't
get the pet I'm kind of hoping
eventually I'll get the pet through
Slayer which I believe will happen but
here I go ahead and get sealed dragons
next uh go ahead and cancel that I hate
sealed dragons are terrible they are AFK
but they're really slow and not really
worth doing in my opinion from there we
go ahead and get neck reels we get 82
magic which is pretty good progress for
the account and from finish off that
task and of course another non AFK task
in Jad but I'm always happy to do a Jad
task free 25k XP another Jad task
completed so no pet initially let's go
ahead and exchange a cape
and
bargain yes I know yeah whatever okay
time to go ahead and get another task
145 fire Giants uh should I do it in the
catacombs wait are they yeah catacombs
let's do it finished off the task but
right now as you guys can see I did end
up selling off everything I needed to
sell so the eclectics I was able to sell
off all 18,000 uh went ahead and put an
offer for another
20K on top of that sold off all the U
saplings for a good four a little over
4K profit which is nice right now U
seeds actually have like a 3K margin so
I'll go ahead and do that a little more
but as you guys can see I bought another
164 for 7 point or 70.9 pretty much and
I can sell them on for 74.8 so that's
another 4K per one giving us about
another 600 700k another task as you
guys can see in the chat oh God Jad
task
[__] I guess I'll do it but 18,000 a
collecting spot which is pretty cool and
of course finish off the Jad task I
don't die as much anymore I'm not that
much of a noob but we didn't get the pet
on the kill and we didn't get it here
either never end up getting the pet man
go on to get some gargoyles not too bad
but I mean they're not great another
task just got done with my gargoyle So
Cal fights yeah
and done with the Cal fight's task so
please be nice to me oh my God bro as
easy as they are they're terrible for
afking an XP so I'm going to go ahead
and cancel them but there we go [__]
that's not AFK either I want some AFK
but I'll take it time for another
task oh my God this is backto back times
I've gotten Jad on the opposite side of
the Italy Rock so happy about that
before this I don't think I've ever
really gotten him over there so it's
just oh such a luxury J kill in the
books so no pet and exchange fire Cape
let's do it I think it's one and three I
should probably just three and one
you're not lucky okay well time to get
another task just like to point out we
did get 85 Slayer in this episode we're
like 60 to 70% of the way towards 87 and
I still haven't got an Abby Demon's task
so if I go ahead and get that that'd be
cool okay I'm canceling that that's like
the Max Steel dragons I think you can
get so not doing that another task and
blood F all right well we can do that
that's easy last postc com of the
episode I actually thought I had a lot
more but as you guys can see I got 50
iron Dragons I'm not about to do that so
go ahead and cancel it and pull
ourselves some dust devils again and
here I am back at the GE of course so I
am selling on eight
Z today junior zamar rocki and Spears
holy [__] for 46.6 mil as you guys can
see I bought it for 46.3 that'd be a
300K profit on top of that all these
eclectics bought for
2961 sold them all off for this so
that's like a 70 GP profit off each
that's like another 350 400k and you
seeds are buying I'm just going to let
them slowly buy but that is where we are
at right now so decent amount of cash
sitting here once he's all sell be
pretty nice first time I've really
started to do this but string jewelry is
something that's decently expensive um
it's not really the best way to go about
training your magic there are better
ways but it's really AFK and if you have
the money to do it I'd recommend it cuz
it just allows you to do so many things
um each inventory you get about 80 I
well each cast I think you get 83 magic
XP so each inventory a little over 2K I
believe uh just really nice or around 2K
I think but it's just really nice it
brings back so many memories from
whenever I was getting uh 94 Magic on my
first account because I remember it was
always something that I couldn't bring
myself to get so this is just this is
great and while I was doing a little bit
more of stringing jewelry went ahead and
sold off an ancestrial Rob bottom for
decent margin right now so uh all these
us saplings would be about like a 6K
profit so there's about 500k right there
as you guys can see I've just kind of
been flipping them a little bit here and
there but ancestrial robe top or bottom
I bought for 106 928 and so there's a
good 900k profit right there and there
we go 85 Mage so probably going to go
ahead and finish up the last of these
little amulet and then go ahead and do
my dust devil stas I've been pushing off
for a while I kind of need to start
trying out this new Slayer Master for
the Wy see what I can do with that so
going to go ahead and finish up my dust
devil task something actually really
nice just happened at the end of the
task though we finish up our totem
pieces we got an entire totem that task
which is really nice and allows me to
pick up some extra loot I believe so
there we go we'll go ahead and grab that
uh and teleport on out of here got to
wait for a hit there we go all right we
are out good task good task uh maybe
another
one all right not bad I'll get on to
that one in the morning but yeah okay so
before I go to bed actually two things
real quick so one Dragon full Helm just
went ahead and bought for 13.2 mil which
is insane because I think I can go ahead
and sell this for around
149 is what I'm going to try to sell it
for overnight that'd be huge merch
really crazy that I was able to buy that
in the first place but we'll keep
another Buy offer in also on top of that
kind of want to show you guys the
collection of stuff stuff I have from
the catacombs so as you guys can see go
ahead and look at totems we have 13
saving those for the skizo update
whenever it has a pet and a I think Helm
recovering and also on top of that
ancient shards we haven't had a reason
to use any of these yet I mean I guess I
could but 57 saved up is also incredible
H it is the morning and now
so as you guys can see was not able to
buy another Dragon full Helm couldn't
Buy on any eclectics I actually was able
to buy a lot of unstung symbols which is
really nice I've been stringing jewelry
as you guys have seen and the insta buy
for 150 and I kind of wanted to slow bu
my future on so that saved me a good
like 300 to I don't know 400k right
there um but the big merch and my
computer is glitching the [__] out all
right and the big merch the Dragon full
Helm so 1.7 mil merch on that not
something you'll see often with the
Dragon full Helm really rare kill me
[__] kill me but anyways we have this
third age Road top so I'm going to go
ahead and see what I can sell this on
for and apparently I can sell it right
now for 6080 so that'd be a good Mill
merch and I'll go ahead and take that
happily so that's not bad that's not bad
we make a mill off this made 1.7 off the
full Helm uh slowly making back what
I've been spending this episode on Magic
um I think it's worth it though uh to
get my magic up pretty quickly uh here
soon we'll be able to go ahead and just
get ourselves like Zora and [__] so I
I'm not I'm not afraid to go ahead and
spend money to get my magic up because
that [__] slow as [__] and there we be
back on the account after class and as
you guys can see by the chat below third
age ROP top has sold so that gives us a
good Old Mill profit or so a little less
uh I was hoping these us saplings would
sell on I bought all the seeds for
around 72k so 5K profit on each but have
given us a meal as well but I think the
price has gone down and it definitely
has so I'm only making about 2K off each
one not that great I mean I'm happy with
it I guess it's free 400k but it's
definitely could be a little better if
people didn't undercut because I know
damn well that's what's going on right
now and Cal fights task done another
task skeletal wyverns I'll take it R in
the [__] just trash gear right now
because I got some uh ge slots filled uh
I don't think anything was bought though
I'm going to go ahead head and probably
buy myself a whip because I'm going to
need it for this task but yeah Buckler
and Elder mul have not bought all right
so finished off the wyvern's task I'm a
[__] idiot and forgot to bring my
Slayer Helm so that task took a little
longer than it needed to be but 131 fire
Giants going to go ahead and Cannon
those pretty quick wait or should I do
them in the catacombs catacombs let's do
it and uh yeah I don't fail
merchesi did here not really failed that
bad I lost 65k off of each one which
brings us to and you know 450k loss but
it was worth it um at the time I would
have made 300K off of each of them H
it's always great to be back man another
task blood felds again I have blood
felds right now on both my accounts
which is a little weird going to go
ahead and can on these I have to upload
a video um shout out big fan big fan
right there I guess somewhat of a decent
merch here so I went ahead and bought
42,000 battle staffs for 8861 and going
to be able to sell them on for 890 which
will give us a 39 GP profit so a decent
160 170k also on top of that a lot of
unstrung symbols bought I'm going to use
these for my own personal gain but as
you guys can see I am actually going to
be able to make a little bit of money on
them if I wanted to because if I'm going
to go ahead and iny one they do not even
buy for 150 which means I could sell
them all for like a 100 or like a 500K
profit but I don't know if it's
necessarily worth it if I do end up
getting the rest of these though I may
have to start selling them off cuz it's
just too good oh my God there we go 87
Slayer this unlocks cave cracken that is
great I still haven't gotten an Abby
demon task I'm not totally pissed but
now we have two boss tests I can do now
I think I might have Shadow barrage
unlocked ah 88 but I could Magic Pot up
and I guess kind of do it so that
wouldn't be bad I guess all right task
is done time to go ahead and get another
one please uh black dragons all right
all right I can deal with some KVD let's
go ahead and do it yeah let's do it all
right so I just accidentally recorded a
clip over YouTube video because I forgot
turn off the sound but I just went ahead
and got a squas task um on top of that
just unlocked the cave Kraken extension
along with the ABY demon extension so
there we go going to do that in the
morning 60k away from 97 strength pretty
hype made a little bit of money so as
you guys can see here I bought I guess
you guys can't see here you guys can see
here I bought a buckler for 34.7 mil
almost sold one off for
35.4 that's a good 700k profit I'm going
to be able to go ahead and sell this one
for what seems to be about 35.2 so we'll
go ahead and make a 600k profit off of
that well I guess more around 500 so 1.2
mil in total I'm trying to sell this on
for 200k loss but I did do two black or
kbd Tas with it so I felt like I got my
money's worth of that definitely would
recommend it though great crossbow hey
oh oh hell yeah well we got them both to
sell at the same time now onto something
else I wanted to do that I didn't think
I'd be able to do this quick and that is
some declaw merges so they have some
insane margins right now I'm going to go
ahead and try to capitalize on it I just
woke up um I did actually have a merch
last night that I didn't record but yeah
so that was a 1.7 mil merch on dclaw
which was really nice to have um that's
why I sold off everything I was pretty
confident that I'd be able to grab one I
was really tired so I didn't go ahead
and get more but I'm going to go ahead
and price check everything we're going
to end off this video so I want to see
real quick what I can sell off these
unstr strong symbols for because I may
actually try to go ahead and sell them
because I don't I I mean I have 20,000
of them almost and I don't need that
many so 48 GP margin on I think I have
what like almost 20K of them I could go
ahead and sell some I guess uh that
wouldn't be too bad at all so I'm going
to go ahead and do that all right so
there we go I'm going to quickly go over
the stuff that we have here right now so
the mal addiction chards 2 I have seven
of them they're worth about 300K so
that's 2 mil we'll say um on top of that
these could actually I mean well not
could will actually sell so we have 2
mil there another 3.6 mil here bringing
us to 5 .6 mil in total the Mythril and
the arum to are worth really nothing but
I just want to go ahead and consider the
5.6 mil that we have over
there now everything's in the bank so
I'm going to go ahead and use a price
checker on uh conduit and I will be back
here in a second all right so I went
ahead and get everything ready so make
sure to add 5.6 mil onto this Bank value
and calculate and
1939 mil so that puts us up to 194 add
on the 5.4 it's pretty much 200 mil I
know didn't make that much progress as
far as money goes this episode we
haven't had a ton of
merchesi so the money should start
pouring in I would imagine here in the
next couple episodes hopefully you guys
enjoyed if you guys did make sure to
leave a like if you guys have anything
you want to tell me go ahead and comment
it down below um also if you guys really
enjoy my content subscribe my Twitter is
in the description as well but other
than that hope you guys have a wonderful
day and
[Music]
peace